my name is Preston Holmes
I'm a solution architect on Google cloud
platform and I work on projects with
connected devices otherwise known as the
Internet of Things or IOT and I want to
start with answering definitively a
question that often comes up and that is
do we have a consensus as to what is IOT
and definitively I'll say no we do not
have any consensus about what exactly
IOT means and so I'm going to give you
my working definition that I find useful
for this and that is that IOT is really
a period of transition and
transformation and that we have everyday
objects things in our lives and they
serve some primary function and that at
some point we begin to connect a few of
these in this sort of awkward phase
where some of them are connected to the
network and many aren't and this is
really IOT that sort of awkward
transition and then eventually as all of
these devices become connected by
default they're no longer really IOT
they just become the things that we have
in our everyday lives and so it's this
transition and more and more of these
things in our lives becoming connected
by default that defines what is IOT
devices now if that's one working
definition of what is IOT then why are
we wanting to connect all these devices
what is that what's the point of it all
and it's really about getting access to
information that wasn't previously
available so there's information in the
environment all the time all around us
but it's not really available to us as
data so this information might be
something like the speed of a delivery
vehicle the utility you today ssin of
parking in a city setting might be more
information about the yield and defect
rate of manufactured products no matter
which vertical or industry you're in
there's probably information that's
valuable to you that you're not getting
any access to today and so this is one
goal for the Internet of Things to go
from information to insight now most of
the data that we deal with today in
data context is born as digital data
clicks on a website application
downloads online commerce transactions
all are born as digital information but
the kind of information we're interested
in in the Internet of Things is analog
and we need a way to capture that analog
information and then locate it to the
places where we can work on it with the
big data tools so really the Internet of
Things becomes the set of technologies
that are the means to this end and this
is really what I mean here when I talk
about an end end solution around IOT now
you've likely been hearing about the
Internet of Things for some time and the
question comes up why hasn't it been
more fully realized and there's a number
of reasons why it's people have been
held back and but first and foremost I
think is really the complexity of the
domain that's involved you've got to
determine and choose some sort of
hardware device platform I've got to
pick whether or not to run an operating
system and which operating system to run
the networking in the Internet of Things
is a lot more varied and diverse some of
these networks are much more spotty much
more expensive there's whole new classes
of networks being built for specifically
for IOT applications you have mobile and
cloud application development each of
which are their own sort of complex
domains and all of these devices have
the potential to generate a lot of data
at scale that might challenge to
traditional data infrastructure and then
finally we all recognize that this has
to be done securely all eyes are on the
security of IOT and the good news is by
paying attention to it early we have the
chance to design security in up front
rather than act reactively which is a
lot of what happened with the web so the
technology and to solve this sort of
end-to-end solution like to break down
sort of an architecture for IOT and
fundamentally we can recognize three
primary components the device which is
the physical object out located in the
real world there's often a gateway which
is responsible for collecting data from
devices and relaying it and then cloud
platform which is increasingly sort of
the
nervous system of your business or
application where this IOT data can be
combined with other non IOT data to sort
of then render useful insight into your
applications now if we look at sort of
other pieces of this technology stack
that data touches throughout come from
sort of bottom to top you'll recognize a
bunch of sort of familiar cloud platform
technology pieces in terms of pipeline
storage analytics etc and across these
things that touch data we recognize a
couple cross-cutting sort of concerns in
the areas of device management and
security and so it's often unclear how
our cloud pieces necessarily fit into
this end-to-end stack so a lot of what
we'll be talking about today is some of
the devices and Gateway pieces so with
this map or framework we can break down
some of the technical considerations and
we'll kind of use this throughout the
talk
starting with devices so as I said
devices are sort of the thing of the
Internet of Things it's the thing out in
the world but a thing might be as small
and simple as a tiny sensor located
inside a door hinge or thing might be as
gigantic as an entire oil rig and these
devices might be compound and mapped in
sort of a hierarchy where you might have
a ship and on that ship is a pump and
both of those are related to each other
both are things and how those are
graphed is going to really depend on
your specific domain model your domain
specialties but at the end of the day a
device is a physical thing out in the
physical world and now a device is
really just a tiny computer so it's both
familiar and foreign you can recognize
all the familiar components of a
computer inside any IOT device
fundamentally it's composed of hardware
and software and it is different than
the computers of our everyday lives
fundamentally the inputs and outputs are
going to be very different and a lot
more sort of exotic than the familiar
mouse and keyboard and monitor that you
have on your computer for sensor inputs
there's a wide variety of sensors
available for gases
for red etc but an input might be as
humble and simple as a button located in
just the right place at just the right
time for somebody to signal some event
has occurred now not all devices are
going to have outputs but outputs can
range as well so you may have something
as simple as a buzzer simply let
somebody know that something's happening
an output can be a gigantic hydraulic
lift that can lift several tons so again
these things are what really define IOT
devices is different now communications
or comms is really technically just
another form of input and output i do
call it out separately because the
diversity of radios and radio types and
communications available for IOT devices
makes communication somewhat of a
special case for in and out of things
now obviously on top of this you run
boot loaders which run and load an
operating system potentially and then
all of your libraries and application
software then runs on this device now
there like I said there's this real
diversity and explosion of hardware
platforms it seems like almost every
week there's new types of boards coming
out new technology but really at the end
of the day as a software developer you
probably think of the device in terms of
the information which it provides how do
i how do i model and manage information
this device is working with and we can
recognize sort of the four primary kinds
of information the first is metadata so
this is really information about the
device this is things like a device
identifier it might include a firmware
version location date installation
location and data etc second is state
this is sort of information about the
condition of the device not necessarily
the condition of the environment but
it's a current condition of the device
might be read read only or read write it
is going to be something that is along
the lines of like the set point for a
thermostat or some sample rate for
frequency and so this is not something
you're going to be changing and
resetting at very high frequencies
commands are a type of information which
indicates some action to be taken by a
device
so this is usually done as some sort of
handler or remote procedure call that's
running on the device and these actions
are often not idempotent which means
that if you send the same command
multiple times you might not be getting
simply the same outcome every time and
you can imagine if you have a command
that says you know run self-cleaning
cycle and you do that once and now
you're clean if you keep running it
multiple times it's not necessarily
going to change the result the same way
it changed it the first time unlike
State and then finally telemetry now
telemetry is really the eyes and ears of
the Internet of Things it's sort of the
the source a lot of what we have is the
environmental data and this telemetry
can take advantage of that diversity of
sensor types I mentioned earlier now if
you're going to bother to sort of define
a device pick hardware platforms and
model the information they they produce
or consume the odds are you going to
have more than one device out there and
as soon as you have more than one device
you need to consider how you're going to
do device management and device
management broadly addresses the tasks
required to make these devices
functional and useful in your project
and this involves pieces of
functionality that run both on the
device as well as in the cloud now a
cloud platform we're pretty versatile in
terms of how we work with you to do
device management we have integrations
with brillo and weave which we'll be
hearing more about later that handles
device management we work with a number
of device management platform partners
who take care of all the edge
communications and setup and
provisioning and there are a number of
open source and sort of do-it-yourself
solutions but no matter which solution
you choose for device management we can
recognize kind of the key functions that
are cheeves
first is you need to provision a device
onto the network it needs to be able to
connect to the local networking
environment where that device sits you
need to register this device in some
sort of registry so you can keep track
of which devices you have under
management you need to authorize a
device you need to make sure that you're
only speaking to devices that are part
of your fleet and you need
to make sure that devices can only reach
the back-end systems they're supposed to
you need to monitor and perform
operational management across a fleet or
groups of devices so that you know that
collectively and aggregate your entire
fleet is performing as you expect it to
and finally you need to be able to
ensure that devices are being up-to-date
now this is not only important for
making sure the devices gaining new
functions over time and new features but
it's critically important for security
that it's always being maintained with
the latest security updates so let's
talk about a couple of customer examples
I want to tell you about how Ness has
been able to simplify the deployment of
connected cameras as part of their
ongoing migration from another cloud
platform so today in the completely
regionalised deployment cameras first
must contact a dispatcher in one region
before connecting to a home server in
another region and then that data is
stored per region and when it's stored
in a single region it gets copied to
other regions for durability and
availability now in contrast the cameras
that are now connecting to Google cloud
platform use our global load balancing
service to immediately reach the
regional server that they ultimately
stay connected to and the data from that
server is stored in services with global
storage scope so they avoid the
complexity of needing to synchronize
data across regions and get that sort of
global availability making objects easy
and pleasant to use and easy to
orchestrate as something philips
Lighting is done successfully with the
hue color changing light bulb it's one
of the more familiar and sort of widely
deployed IOT devices out in the world
many of you may have one now Philips
with the help of one of our partners q42
was able to build and scale the
infrastructure to support the hue
application and API on cloud platform
this low latency and reliable API is
part of the hue experience and Philips
and Hugh Phillips and q42 we're able to
take advantage of some features in
container engine to allow the backend to
this system to be steadily improved and
steadily released by taking advantage
of features such as rolling updates on
container engine they're also able to
launch new and interesting small
experiments with very very quickly on
their existing container engine cluster
and it almost no cost no additional cost
to run those experiments side by side
and all of that container engine
infrastructure is then able to connect
to our data and analytics and monitoring
platforms elsewhere on cloud platform so
the light bulb is a great example of a
device which by itself cannot reach
cloud platform and I'd mentioned
gateways in in the beginning and all hue
light bulbs ship with sort of a gateway
or hub and I said this is often a key
component in IOT architectures and I
want to explain a little bit more about
why that's so and it comes down to
there's a whole class of devices out
there that are not able to reach the
cloud for one reason or another this
might be that they do not have any
routable connectivity to the internet
for example bluetooth is not directly
routable to tcp/ip it might be that they
don't have the processing capability to
perform the secure HTTP transport
protocol that all of our cloud platform
api is required it also might be that
they don't have the power budget in
order to support the networking they may
be very low power and finally there are
perspectives in a setting the required
device to look at multiple devices in
that area and do some pre computing so
any one device isn't going to give you
that local aggregate and pre-processing
setting and that's part of what a
gateway can do so we have a demo outside
running with Intel one of our partners
in the Gateway space is until they make
an industrial IOT gateway platform and
we've worked with them on an integration
with cloud pub/sub and the scenario
we've worked on is this idea of tracking
the environmental conditions and
locations of pallet goods so this starts
with an Eddystone Bluetooth beacon now
Eddystone is an open-source Bluetooth
spec from Google defines a couple data
types that are broadcast over bluetooth
including an ID as well as telemetry
frames for things like temperature or
humidity
and the Gateway collects these from the
Bluetooth beacon and then sends the
information up to pub/sub on the Gateway
is also developer experience a sort of a
developer UI that you can easily connect
various sensors directly to the Gateway
and then these automatically gain from
this integration to cloud pub/sub the
Gateway also runs a set of libraries for
doing runtime edge processing and this
is useful when you have networking where
you want to be somewhat miserly about
what you're actually transmitting on the
network to the cloud so if you can do
some degree of edge processing you can
really send up the right quantity and
kind of condensed version of information
and so this idea of connectivity being a
specific challenge in IOT solutions
comes up because the location where this
information you're interested in in is
going to be potentially who knows what
kind of environment and the world is not
blanketed with Wi-Fi Wi-Fi is limited to
sort of the places where people are
today for the most part and so one of
the ways we're looking at helping extend
connectivity to cloud platform through
partners is with a project we're doing
with particle i/o now particle is one of
the more widely used Internet of Things
platforms they've got over 60,000
developers on their platform already and
most recently they released the
electron-electron is a small powerful
IOT device with built-in cellular
connectivity and so this gives you the
ability to have this device connect to
the cloud in over a hundred countries
we've partnered with particle to make it
easier than ever to pipe data from any
connected particle device directly into
Google cloud pub/sub now anyone who's
visited Google may have seen these
colorful bikes that we have all around
campus called G bikes and and as
Google's campus has grown the G bike has
been come this sort of key way that
people get from building the building
throughout the day but the team that
operates G bikes for Google has very
little visibility into where these bikes
tend to go during the day and how they
tend to clump and where they are so
working with particle we've sort of
attached some of these particle
electrons to bikes and we're able to
collect the locations of how they move
throughout campus during the day we
stream this through pub/sub into
bigquery and then we can run queries
that allow us to plot their locations
with heat map API is in Google Maps this
is really invaluable for that G bike
team to understand what the usage is and
where these bikes are throughout the day
so connectivity involves things like
networks but it also involves things
like protocols yesterday we announced
support alpha support 4G RPC for pub/sub
and G RPC is an open-source binary
protocol that will be supporting across
many of our products but in IOT there
are other protocols that are very
commonly found and one of those is MQTT
so a partner of ours augusto has been
working on building an MQTT solution on
compute engine MQTT as a protocol is
well suited for IOT it's it has a very
low footprint both in terms of network
usage but also is available as libraries
for many small microcontroller devices
today and so what Agosto has done is
build a custom MQTT Broker that is based
on RabbitMQ and it allows us to focus
the protocol translation from MQTT to
pub/sub and let's pub/sub as a managed
service handle all of the durability and
manage scale of storage of events so the
compute engine we can focus on using the
networking performance and CPU
performance but not necessarily worry
about storing all of the events and this
solution allows you to scale this out
from pilot to production very
cost-effectively now
what I've been talking about today is
how things get solved today this this
domain of complexity is all solvable but
it can get definitely better and at
Google we're working on making it better
across the experience and it's been part
of our DNA to work with devices from
Android phones to chromecast and
Chromebooks so invite Jeff Chen product
manager from brillo and weave to tell
you more about the brillo and weave
project at brillo and how we're looking
to improve devices like you Preston
good afternoon so my name is Jeff Chen
I'm one of the product managers on the
Google brillo and weave team so I'm a
device guy the hardware guy and so I
wanted to first introduce to you what
brillo and weave are this is Google's
offering specifically in the IOT space
well when we sought out to build out
brillo and weave we wanted to address
three major objectives the first one is
that we wanted to help device makers a
build for IOT so at Google we have been
building connected devices Android
Chromebooks chromecast and so on and we
realize that these solutions could be
benefited from third party device
manufacturers because they struggle with
trying to figure out how to make a
device's cost effectively or be able to
build with security so we wanted to help
device makers prototype their device
applications quickly and then more
importantly port that over to the
production hardware without requiring
major surgery and it doesn't end there
with connected devices it's really
important to be a position where you can
actually monitor the devices that are in
the field and be able to push out
updates to them to resolve any security
concerns or to update new features to
continue to improve the user experience
secondly we wanted to create an open
ecosystem as we observe the growth of
these IOT ecosystems we saw that there
were subnets of siloed ecosystems that
were causing more and more fragmentation
and while there were some very good
reasons for vendors to lock down the
connectivity of these devices with
proprietary protocols it keeps us from
getting to this truly open Internet of
Things
and so the only way that we can get into
this Internet of Things is by embracing
open and standardized communication
protocols which leads us to the third
and final objective that we had and that
is that we can create an ecosystem of
devices with open protocols so that we
can create a rich ecosystem of apps and
services that could be transformative so
think about the web think about mobile
Android now the intelligence and the
sports of these devices will not come
from a single vendor nor from Google it
comes from you developers developers
that want to build applications and
services that can communicate across
devices from different brands and I can
build rich analytics around these
devices to help make these devices
better and more useful to the user so
that's why we built brillo and weave
because ultimately we see that the magic
comes from a distributed world of
devices and we think that the power of
this new internet would require the
ecosystem to build devices
cost-effectively and F scale these
devices have to communicate with each
other through open protocols where the
smarts are in the device on clients or
in the cloud so let me tell you about
what brillo is well brillo is an
operating system that's maintained by
Google it is a version of Android and it
is supported by a variety of silicon
vendors and it has proven scale to reach
over 1 billion Android devices right so
we recognize that deploying a full-blown
stack of Android is a little bit
overkill for connected devices so we
built a stripped-down version that was
targeted specifically for a connected
devices so device manufacturers can
leverage all of the benefits of the
Android hardware ecosystem so if a chip
vendor supports Android it can
essentially support brillo now the
second aspect of brillo is about
security and brillo enables devices to
be secure because we fundamentally we
believe
security has to be built into the device
for IOT technology when we believe that
not only do you need to have it built in
but you also need a way to be able to
fix issues that are in the field as they
come up so we've built a number of
security features into brillo that will
address these problems including
verified boot which means that the
device will run code that is trusted
from the manufacturer we also make sure
that access to the device and all the
data that's produced through these
devices is controlled by the user and
that any data that is actually stored on
the device or transmitted across the
communication pathways are all getting
cryptid and secured and then lastly with
brillo it comes with services like
analytics and updates so for example
device manufacturers can get a readout
of all the features and the usage of
their device population in aggregate and
figure out how the users are using their
devices but then also we provide an
infrastructure to push updates so that
as security threats come up or you see
new features that you want to deploy
that you can have a pathway to be able
to push those updates to those devices
now for weave what is we've what we've
is our open communications platform it
consists of three components a device
library client API and a web server
cloud server if you build weave into
your device it's easy for third-party
application developers to access your
weave devices from their phone or a
cloud service through weave mobile and
cloud api's we believe in
interoperability so much that we built
out device schemas for a specific set of
device categories so that third-party
app developers could use these schemas
to build apps to monitor the device
state to control them and to build
analytics and richer experiences across
all of these devices and in addition to
offering third party API s
we've also offers seamless integration
into Google services such as the Google
Voice assistance
so with brillo and weave devices this
platform enables an ease of use and ease
of building devices and creating a
standardized device data and we expect
these devices to generate data and a lot
of it so Google cloud platform for IOT
data offers a proven end-to-end solution
to make sense of large amounts of data
and produce meaningful insights these
insights can help manufacturers
determine what features to add or remove
on the product help app makers develop
novel new experiences and services and
help enterprises manage their fleet of
devices for optimal performance and
security so that gives you a little bit
of an overview of what Google is doing
in the device ecosystem to enable with
operating system brillo and a
communications platform called weave so
our team looks forward to all them
amazing and awesome things that you guys
are going to be doing on the cloud side
to take advantage of these smart and
connected devices
thank you all heading back to Preston
so I said earlier much of what we've
talked about today has been about the
technology of the Internet of Things
that runs outside of the context of
cloud platform now this is important
because unless you clearly understand
how the on-ramps for IOT data work and
how to solve for them you can't take
advantage of all the great big data
tools we have on cloud platform so it's
important to understand how to get the
data onto the cloud but without a doubt
data and analytics is our strong suit on
cloud platform and the key here is that
we provide a comprehensive platform for
working with IOT data and what's
interesting is as we follow this data
through the journey from the edge to the
application it begins perhaps is highly
specific data that might be coming from
a machine specific industrial protocol
or healthcare device but as it moves and
is ingested into the platform and
processed and normalized and
standardized into the structured data
that's well suited for our big data tool
chain it begins to lose some of its IOT
specificity our temperatures just become
integers and cycle times on machines
become just timestamps and so as our
general-purpose big data tool chain
processes and sort of munches this IOT
data it then becomes a bit more generic
and as it moves out into the application
is where it really regains this domain
specificity because at the end of the
day the insights and and sort of queries
that you run against the data are what
turned this volume of data into the
useful sort of actionable level insights
that you need to then present back to
processes or users through applications
and this is really why application sort
of called out here separately and I want
to tell you one such application that
we've incubated at Google for work and
launched in a multi store pilot with a
retail customer is a solution which
provides digital inventory visibility
and accuracy now this works by putting
RFID tags on every item in the store
readers then on the ceiling can scan
the store and basically generate a live
inventory feed of what is both in the
front of the store and the back of the
store this application then generates
the sort of steady stream of the
real-time view of the inventory up to
cloud platform where it's processed and
analyzed and then made available as an
application to store associates now
store associates can take this
information and it boosts their
visibility into the accuracy of their
inventory in store upwards of 95 percent
compared to the 60 to 70 percent
typically gained through a standard
point-of-sale system and this allows
them to track inventory in the back room
to the front of the store to make sure
that product is always present where
customers need it the corporate office
this also gives all sorts of visibility
about changing and adapting marketing
campaigns adopting store HR hours etc
and once infrastructure such as this is
in place it begins subsequent ideas for
other applications that can bring sort
of what we're once considered far off
future ideas of sort of virtual changing
rooms and Tryon stores touchless payment
and checkout systems etc so this is
going to bring us back to security now
and security like device management is
something that needs to touch the entire
sort of data handling stack and end and
you all were in the keynote earlier
hopefully you heard how much attention
we pay to security and cloud platform
it's something that Google takes very
seriously in cloud platform builds into
the fabric of all of our products and
services now for IOT it's important that
we offer both secure api's and methods
for bringing the data onto the platform
securely as well as sort of the security
controls and foundations to make sure
that you're able to keep that data
secure once it's on the cloud on the
device side you've heard about about
brillo and weave device security needs
to be built into the fundamental systems
and technologies you're choosing so
sandboxing allows the protection of one
process from another over-the-air
updates and
verified boots make sure that you're
running secure code and always able to
push out the latest secure versions
keeping user data secure on the device
and in transit to the cloud is very
important for consumer applications as
well as quote has sort of commercial
applications and finally using secure
Linux technologies such as mandatory
access controls limits the power of any
exploit from doing more damage in taking
control of the device but it's not
enough for us to just do what we can at
Google to really secure the Internet of
Things requires collaboration across a
broad ecosystem of partners so one of
the challenges in IOT applications is
maintaining this end-to-end integrity
and secure ownership of a device so I
want to tell you about this
collaboration we'll work on with Intel
and the technology they're calling
Marshall point the idea is that by
taking a Hardware proof of
authentication in this technology Intel
calls epi' deal isince to add Mel and
microchip that a new owner of a device a
new service of advice can meet at a
virtual rendezvous point the
manufacturer the previous owner of that
device and digitally sort of through
some cryptographic signatures take new
ownership of that device and securely
provision it with application or cloud
credentials and so this is an example of
what I think it takes to really secure
the IOT end end because if you have any
gap in that chain that becomes a sort of
an unacceptable point of surface to
breach your system overall
so in conclusion why do you want to get
started building IOT now well it is a
fantastic time with the hardware that's
the the proliferation and the diversity
of sensors and platforms and hardware
it's never been easier to get started
with hardware today second Google is
bringing its expertise and experience
working with both devices and data
across the entire spectrum of the IOT
problem space and third we do so with an
utmost focus on security throughout
as you've been hearing so I encourage
you all to think about the analog
information that's relevant to you and
out there in the world today and to go
start building solutions to capture and
process that information lone cloud
thank you very much we'll let you get
cut free lunch if anyone has questions
Jeff and I will be datacom thank you
you